this
is star talk it's cosmic queries edition
chuck nice what's happening you're
always there for me that's right my
friend
that's right i'm glad you'd like
learning because otherwise
this would be a really crappy job for
you well
uh i i'm glad i like learning too
for for reasons other than just even
this
yes i think it's great your mama would
be proud
the school teacher that she was that's
right that's right yeah exactly maybe
that's where i get it from you know
there you go it's very cool so with
cosmic queries and occasionally
you know the bag of cosmic queries
collects and
sometimes they don't fit into categories
so we've made a category
called no category i like that
okay cosmic queries no category no cat
beyond description
yes so all right we'll see we'll see
what we got yeah
we'll just pull them out so this is you
know all right here we go let's uh
let's get to uh we've got some patreon
members always up front with
patreon thank you for your money guys
we appreciate you that's patreon patrons
victor sanchez says all right
knowing that dark gravity is out there
but we don't know how it got there
could it be the dark gravity is the
residual
energy from a dead black hole as stephen
hawking
had a theory that black holes do
eventually die
after a very very very long time
and that's the end of that question but
that's an interesting question who asked
that
that was uh victor sanchez okay very
good very interesting question
i think we've had gun questions from him
before yes we have yeah
there's a regular and clearly he's
he's literate no knowing that black
holes
evaporate yeah and and he did some
name drops stephen hawking yes and the
hawking radiation and the whole
deal right you know let me just remind
people
or alert you if you've never known that
black holes
evaporate all evidence all theoretical
evidence points
to the fact that they evaporate and the
way this happens is
the energy of their gravitational field
is so high
that it spontaneously creates matter
out of it that's right unbelievable yeah
yeah yeah yeah
energy and matter on the opposite sides
of that equation
equals m c squared so if so matter can
become energy energy can become matter
that's how that works and that's the
recipe
if you're going to make that happen in
your kitchen so at the
just outside the event horizon of a
black hole
what you can make is spontaneously
fabricate particles from that energy
field
and when you make particles out of
energy you make a particle and an
anti-particle
right that's the rule that's just how
that that's how the universe rolls
and they fly in opposite directions okay
so one falls back into the black hole
the other escapes
it turns out that when the black hole
loses
energy from its gravitational field
it's the same thing as it having lost
mass
same thing wow so in fact the black hole
weighs a little less for this
and this just keeps going it's very slow
and it's not very efficient
take a long time but eventually the
entire black hole
dissipates back into space and it only
takes
3 trillion years
actually a little longer really wow well
the black holes in the centers of
galaxies
if you run the math on those it'll it'll
take about a google years
oh my god yeah yeah yeah very long time
that's a long
long okay yeah so so there's in fact
there's a long tradition of those
interested in my field
to look in the very distant future of
the universe
so uh there's a colleague of mine who
wrote a book the five ages of the
universe
and his last name is adams you can look
it up and he
uh in it there's the age of like stars
okay
fine all right well is what is another
age well when all the stars are dead
and all you have are black holes then
the only energy coming out
is the black hole evaporation right then
you have this era of just black holes
evaporating
all right but that's a way long in the
future and that takes a really long time
but nothing else is happening
so you get to label it by that according
to what the primary thing that's going
on over that time
so relative to that period in the
universe the age of stars is just a blip
so so anyhow so the question was
could the dark energy the dark gravity
be
sort of the spirit energy left over in
the
field of a black hole that's right i
think that's the question and the answer
is no
okay okay and there you go stephen
thanks for playing
the answer is no so no here's the thing
it's the if you run the history of the
universe back
whatever it is that is the dark gravity
the dark the the dark matter whatever
that is
it cannot physically interact
with ordinary matter because if it did
it would completely
change what the universe looked like so
it has to have gravity
and not interact with us and a black
hole
does both does interact with sorry black
hole has gravity
right but the particles that evaporate
out of it we interact with those
particles those are like it's regular
matter that comes out
so no so you can't you can't appeal to
black holes for that
yeah exactly sorry um yeah
you actually you can't appeal to a black
hole for anything
you can try they're so unreasonable it's
just like
bro bro why do you got to take
everything you're such a taker such an
ugly reason with you know i should
i should tweet that reason with a black
hole cannot reason with a black hole
all right so um basically this is just
out of curiosity based on what you just
said so now um
since we cannot interact with it and it
does have gravity so this is this force
is it possible that this force well just
i want to be clear
that you can interact with
this stuff gravitationally right exactly
there that's
right but the this whole other level of
interaction that i'm talking about is
why we even exist
it's the fact that the material can come
together and make atoms and molecules
and that's why you're this physical
thing that i can touch and you're
you're a physical entity that is matter
collected doing other interesting things
as a collected unit dark what we
call dark matter or dark gravity has no
such properties right
because we right and that's why we don't
know what it is because it doesn't have
those
correct we don't we don't know what it
is because it doesn't interact with
light
or or the energy or electromagnetic
forces
right so now is it possible then that
it's kind of a platform that predates
all of us and when i say all of us i
mean the universe
uh yes well it's there for it was there
from the beginning
right so i don't know that it predates
us but it co-dates us
okay and it is and we here's a way to
say it
its presence shaped what matter did
afterwards
so in that sense it pre it it's it
pre-organized us
organized yeah wow wow
so so here it is so it's it'd be like
looking at an ocean
at night at like late twilight
and you see sort of the white caps on
the on this
like maybe it's a gently moonlit night
if all you could see are the white caps
you say oh
the ocean is just these little white
caps and then the sunrise is like
there's a whole ocean there right okay
and you realize that white caps are just
these little
it's evidence of there being water but
it is a
small fraction of the total water that's
there so
we spent our whole lives finding
galaxies in the universe thinking that
that was the
material representation of matter in the
cosmos turns out
no these are the galaxies are found
where dark matter has collected them
right
there it is ah so so in some galaxy
clusters
there's a hundred a thousand times more
dark matter than regular matter
right wow so so we we
are the froth on the waves oh man
god can't we just can't we be can we be
the foam in a cappuccino i don't want to
be
i don't want to be the frog little wavy
if an italian had come up with it then
maybe that's what they that's what it
might have been
cool all right hey victor great question
my friend was that song from was it the
1970s all we are is dust in the water
we are it's dust in the wind all we are
is froth on the in the way
i'm so glad they didn't write this off
that way
all we are is froth in the waves all
right here we go or
white caps no no that would that was all
white caps in the open ocean okay
and i like dust in the wind a little
better okay i'm gonna cut with dust
because we had a beautiful tune with it
but yeah yeah that's what you need you
need actually that's what you need now
is a melody
all right yeah all right how about uh
glenn from glenn
glenn glenn's like cher glenn does not
need a last name
he's just glenn it's just glenn all
right the problem is there's a zillion
glenn's out there
[Laughter]
i feel bad if your name is sharon you
got to have a last name
all right so uh glenn says
how can we tell when an area is obscured
by a black hole or whether it's just an
empty area of space how much of our
view of the night sky is obscured by
objects such as a black hole
so all right so so so space is mostly
empty wow okay i think we said on a
previous broadcast i gave the example of
how empty
space oh my god and it's it's it's
mind-boggling you ready
mind-boggling you look at a sentence
printed on a page
and then the sentence ends with a period
right
i think in europe they call it a full
stop but there it is a period
if the sun were the size of that period
then
and everything shrunk to match that
match data
the next closest star is four miles away
that's unbelievable yeah i mean
seriously every time i get that
right so when you i mean you got to
imagine that scale and the distance of
four miles because we all know what four
miles is
well we all know and we all know what a
single kilometers right and we all know
how small a period here it is
right so so what i'm saying is as you
look out into space
your sight line is not
accidentally bumping into anything
okay it looks like the knight is filled
with stars because you're
you're finding the stars to look at if
you just close your eyes and like
through a dart
it would just go here hit the enough
inverse yeah hit nothing wow
the all air all space space
so so no the space is not crowded so
that things are blocking your view what
you know
sorry you know it does block your views
huge gas clouds they block your view
right because they're huge the manifold
time is larger
than the solar system whole star
clusters are formed out of such gas
clouds right so you know they're huge
and radio waves pass right through them
which is why radio waves
is the band of choice for aliens
if you want to talk to aliens or you
want to hear what message they have
they probably know if they're smart
that radio waves pass through all the
obscuring dust and gas
in the galaxy so you would use that if
you used
visible light then it would just get
absorbed or scattered and you wouldn't
be able to communicate
so radio waves we'll go through but
ordinary light
visible light no so guest house can
block your view
in fact the milky way at night there are
these
dark lanes and people thought oh that's
where they're
100 years ago oh that's where there are
no stars maybe we see
through the galaxy to the rest of the
universe no they're dark
clouds that are actually obscuring your
view from what's behind it
and that took a long while to figure out
wow
consider this in australia the the
native aborigines and like everybody
else in the world they had
cosmic lore about what they see in the
night sky
and to them they identified not the
brighter areas of the milky way but the
dark
areas they gave meaning
to the absence of light wow rather than
to the presence of light
and in fact one of the largest dark
lanes is called the great emu
in the sky very very local uh
fauna yeah uh and if you look at it it's
like yeah it's got a tall neck and it's
got a beak area
so it's an emu so just it's an
interesting distinction between
a western concept that something has to
give you light for it to exist as a
thing
and in australia where the absence of
light was the thing itself
so so they're working in negative spaces
yes as the
as the designers would say yeah so so
now how would you know a black hole is
there because it's completely distorting
all the imagery surrounding it right
because it
the fabric of space and time
doesn't send light in straight lines it
curves and you will see this
so if you if you travel through space
and all of a sudden
your images start taking these circular
distorted patterns
back to hell right exactly that's a
detour
sign that's the that's the detour sign
of the cosmos
there you go get the hell out of that
out of the bath so yes you would know
black holes if they were in front of you
cool
all right so let's move on uh let's take
one more patreon patron
this is travis mansfield and he says do
you think spacex
is just a front to a larger armageddon
conspiracy
like maybe we already know that a huge
asteroid is going to hit
earth and uh and this is our only hope
uh i'm not authorized to comment on that
next next question
all right chuck we've got to wrap it up
but that's a really good question
and see what i did there i'm making it
wait a little teaser a little teaser
commercial yeah yeah yeah
so when we come back more cosmic queries
galactic
edition we're going to talk about i'm
going to touch on
conspiracy theories when we return
we're back cosmic queries galactic gumbo
edition
which is a category unto itself that
questions are completely random out of
this bag
uh so we left off with a cliffhanger on
conspiracy theories so chuck j read the
whole question again
we're on the same page here go okay cool
travis mansfield do you think spacex is
just a front for a larger armageddon
conspiracy
like maybe we already know that a huge
asteroid will hit the earth
and uh martian colonization is our only
hope boom
so here's the thing here's the thing uh
as you know we upload billions of photos
and videos to the internet
every day let's just start there okay
second
a conspiracy requires
many people participating in a lie
on a level where the temptation to let
others know
is somehow removed from people's
behavior
and so i
and it would require the government
to successfully pull this off and
anyone who's worked for the government
knows
how inept they are at keeping secrets
yeah or doing anything organized at such
a level
right so i think the urge to
want to believe that conspiracies are
driving everything that's happening
around us
needs a deeper psychological explanation
that we don't currently have okay
so ask the psychologist why you want to
believe there's a conspiracy
that's that's really what we should
doing here not asking
i think there's a conspiracy convince me
that it isn't
why do i think there's a conspiracy is
the real question that's the question
that's it exactly uh so travis there's
your answer
um we're going to send you the number of
several therapists
and um have at it my friend have at
it uh there's a there's a there's a
couple
there's a couple tele-dialers in there
yeah there's a couple that you could do
through tele like you know zoom and it's
it's
listen it's a good thing my friend it's
a good thing
so at some point you have to ask why
don't you
completely flesh out the conspiracy just
put in all the details you need
okay it would mean the government has
discovered an asteroid that's going to
destroy us all right
and they're keeping that a secret and
everyone else in the world who has a
telescope
who can detect it somehow is missing it
but only the government caught it
right then the government is putting in
a is
secretly negotiating with spacex to
build spaceships
that we can then an arc basically to
collect maybe two by two of only the
chosen ones
in the world so they can go to mars as
we terraform mars
because we've been practicing this with
the
the air the contrails of airplanes for
the last several decades so
all of this comes together now just
think that through and how many people
that involves
and how many people would have to keep
that a secret
okay just put all that together and then
ask yourself
is that viable and feasible is isn't it
easier that just
tell us is it easier to just tell us
we're gonna die
no no no no isn't it just a simpler
explanation to say
no the government doesn't have this kind
of secret information about the night
sky because anyone else could then have
access to it and there's no way they can
keep that a secret
on top of that we just have someone as a
modern-day thomas edison and he's
building and inventing stuff
exactly and it's great and we all look
forward to whatever the next and he's
very transparent
about his successes and his failures
whole youtube compilations
of his rockets that blew up on the
launch pad that's so true
none of this sounds like a secret to me
that's all
okay you know what that's um that was an
extremely
salient and thoughtful answer to
this question because you know see and
this is why you're an educator
because me i'm just like man
shut up let's go but and i don't mean
that to you
travis i'm not talking about the points
a little more patience yeah i'm not as
patient as what i'm saying you know like
come on and let's you know but
but no that i think that's i think it's
good that people heard you
kind of walk through because what you
just said is applicable
to any conspiracy that you might
subscribe
to correct and my favorite version of
these
is i think i saw it in a meme but i can
i'll just retell it
so neil armstrong and buzz aldrin of
apollo 11 fame
agreed to fake the moon landing
but they really wanted to be as
authentic looking as possible
and urged nasa to do it on location
and nasa agreed
[Laughter]
oh my god that's insane i love it
so so there you have it okay
hi chuck next question all righty
let's go to belt fed joe
belt fed yes okay belt fed joe from
tucson
arizona i don't even know what that
means i don't either but
uh apparently beltfed does
apparently where's mama did yeah
somebody somebody knows the deal
and uh not us yet and he says uh
that astron uh arizona is the astronomy
mecca now i thought it was new mexico
neil but he says it's arizona
is there an astronomy mecca uh yeah i
would
say hawaii but um okay yeah yeah because
they have a 14 000
foot mountain uh the big island where
you're above
clouds and we have telescopes there and
okay uh
yeah so if there was is that is that if
i have to pick a state
where you say the most significant
astronomy happened right arizona would
be maybe a close second
close second here's arizona's claim to
fame go ahead ready
okay in tucson arizona right the nearest
town to
nearest uh important city to
an observatory called kitt peak okay
they have a relationship kitt peak
observatory
and tucson kid peek said in order for us
to continue to do our science you can't
keep making your city brighter at night
because you'll interfere with our
observations so let's work together
to reduce the nighttime illumination
because it creates a sky glow and
interferes with your ability to see the
stars at night
so they got together and all the street
lights
have these sort of caps on them so the
light only points downward
and the and by the way if it only points
downward you don't need half the wattage
you previously had to illuminate the sky
think about it if you're flying over a
city in an airplane and you see a street
light
somebody is paying to have that street
light send photons to you
in the sky in your seat in the airplane
what the hell good is that
so this is very sensible recommendations
which saves the town money saves the
astronomical dark skies
and this set of audience ordinances the
dark sky ordinances
have been copied by many other cities
around the world well there you go
belt fed joe you uh
you may not be the astronomical mecca
but you certainly
are super important that's cool yes and
new mexico also has a quite a
fun suite of telescopes right so as and
so
both together i would say and why
because there's a lot of desert climate
within them and you don't put a
telescope in a rain forest
right you put it where there's no clouds
or a minimum of clouds
and new mexico arizona southern
california uh satisfy that
okay all right so this is what he says
are the sizes masses of planets
proportional to the distance between
planets is the composition a factor
are there any exceptions that's a great
question because you might ask
if i have a lot of space between me my
nearing neighboring planets
did i eat everything right all right and
would i then be the biggest
planet right okay you could think about
it that way
um there's some truth to that perhaps
um jupiter's big it's the biggest planet
of them all
right but saturn has more room between
it and jupiter and it and
uranus than jupiter has between it and
mars and it
and saturn so it's not a
direct one-to-one relationship
right so because in fact saturn is twice
as far away from the sun as jupiter is
and then uranus is twice again as far
away right so
it's so there's way more space out there
but it doesn't always mean this
and by the way when you look at early
modelings of the formations of solar
systems
stuff it's it's it's a shooting gallery
it's it's it's mean
back then stuff is slamming in it's a
pinball machine
it's a pinball machine yeah where the
where the ball stick together
whether to stick together or blow each
other apart right
one or the other worst pinball game ever
so so when we do this it's a
um when you run those simulations you
find
many objects that might have hung around
and collected more material
competing with the material you want to
collect it gets ejected from the solar
system entirely
or sent down to to plunge into the sun
and vaporize
so it doesn't precisely work that way
but i say
by and large if you have a bigger sort
of gravitational zone
we would expect you to be bigger but
it's not a perfect it's not a perfect
relationship
all right cool nice question yeah by the
way yeah he ended by saying
tyson nye 2020. okay might be a little
late for you to get on the ballot but
still
there's the sentiment okay all right
there you go all right let's go to
michael g
thompson from facebook and michael says
if i was on an alien planet
many light years away but i had a
telescope a powerful telescope
powerful enough to see people on distant
planets
what would it be what would be possible
based on how far away my alien planet is
would it be possible for me to see
actual roman battles taking place if i
were looking here at earth
yes if you are at the distance in light
years
from earth that corresponded to the time
in the past that those roman battles
took place so
when when did you have the coliseum
that's to say 2000 years ago
the time of jesus right because that's
the whole storyline there
right um and so find a star
2000 light years away get
park yourself on a planet there you have
to do that now and get a nice big
telescope aim it towards earth and you
will see the roman coliseum
in real time wow well delay time right
exactly in your real time
correct and they're gone time
there's a galaxy is it m101 or m100
there's a
beautiful spiral galaxy that's 65
million light years away
from the milky way so you know i want to
go there and look back
right what do i get to see the beginning
of everything here
65 million years ago well not the
beginning of everything but the
beginning of what we you know
this this 65 chuck 65 million years ago
was wasn't that the dinosaurs yes thank
you that's what i said the beginning of
everything
now the beginning of this crap i call
that i forget that's what you that's
what that's what you'd write on an exam
trying to get partial credit because you
didn't remember it was dinosaurs
i said i said dinosaurs but anyway i was
trying to think
i wrenched it out of you no i was trying
to think which which
scene it was like you know is it the
plisty scene
oh yeah yeah that's what i was trying to
think of but and
they got a little bit of a renaming so
it's no longer the kt
boundary okay um and but uh there's a
more accurate
less memorable name that it's been given
okay but the point is that boundary the
65 million year ago boundary
uh an asteroid struck earth took out the
dinosaurs that's it
wreaked havoc uh you bear witness to
that
right from this galaxy 65 million years
ago that's so cool and you couldn't even
say look out
you couldn't even
well you can't warn anybody yeah warn
anybody already happened you got to sit
there and watch
it because you're watching or you're
watching a re-run damn it's already
happened
so so the point is you can't
go there from here to see your past
right
who knows you could if you could beat
the light beam right
so see that's so let me ask you this
what you just said now that sparks in me
this okay
you can't get there but if you were
already there you could see the pass
so now that says all right why is it
then that we can move
up and down back and forward left and
right on this
axis right but we can't move back
in time if theoretically like we can't
not even theoretically we can't do it
you gotta let me you gotta beat the
light in order to do it
let me let me reask your question you're
saying if time is a coordinate like all
the other coordinates right and we can
move back and forth in x y and z why
can't we move back and forth in time
right that's the question yes yes okay
so
it isn't it is indeed true we are
prisoners
of the present forever transitioning
from our inaccessible past to our
unknowable future
now see i asked you a question and you
didn't turn it into a dog going poetry
slam
i mean that is beautiful what you just
said it's gorgeous but
yeah so um it would be very interesting
if you could step out of your timeline
and then
rejoin yourself um yeah
either in your future or in your past
and
but that kind of would imply that your
timeline is predetermined
in the same way the coordinate the
coordinate is right because that
coordinates are definitely predetermined
if i step over there
right um that's been there's waiting for
me to step there interesting
it doesn't invent itself as i arrive and
it's there
okay so oh so now wait hang on we got to
take a break
oh crap man because i gotta notice
because you bring up pre-determination
and then you say we gotta take a break
time for a break you're worse than my
therapist just what i'm about to have a
breakthrough he's like and that's all we
have time for today
when we come back more cosmic aquarius
galactic gumbo edition we're talking
about
uh i guess in this moment time travel
remember your turn
shark have you calmed down
your therapist on speed dial exactly
so you asked a very important question
why can't we move on our time coordinate
right if it is what everyone what the
physicists say it is it's just another
it's
just another coordinator exactly three
right no it is a little different
because it
we are prisoners of its present right
that's why
it's a little different but if you could
step out of that coordinate
yeah you could go backwards you could go
back and forth so so so now that so then
you bring up
this is more philosophical than it is
you know physics but
you know i'm going to ask um speaking of
stepping out so that you know connotes
uh infers uh if your mama over here
we infer it implies it implies correct
okay right
i was about to say i'm a mother an
english teacher yes she was i was
what i should have said was i'm
inferring
that's what i should have said but uh
because
i'm not sure if it implies but i'm
inferring that
that would um that would connote the
unfolding of time as opposed to
the pre-determination of time if what
if we're if we lack the ability to step
out of these coordinates and look at our
timeline
thereby being able to identify a point
in the past and go back
does that mean that being a prisoner of
the present means
that the present is not determined
because there are some people who
believe in predetermination
yeah i mean it i mean maybe pre-i mean
yeah i i don't know okay
because that's a rough that's a crazy
thing that you just would are you
suggesting that if you could step out
right it would require that it's
predetermined yes so the fact that we
can't step out
is the evidence that maybe we have free
will
and you know that's it's funny because
when you see when you say it that way
free will be
i think brings in a completely different
philosophical discipline but i
but but i i look at it more as a
and it as a present unfolding more so
than i look at
free will which which means that we have
some
influence okay maybe not free will
because that's
so philosophical but we have some
influence
like yeah the problem is if you rejoined
yourself in the past
and you changed something that prevented
you from stepping out of your future
then you could not have rejoined you
yourself in the past damn so there's a
it's it's a ti it's a it's a causality
conjecture
violation right um which stephen hawking
had proposed
that he suggested there will never be
backwards time travel and one day we
will discover why
um and it's called it's a time it's a
time protection cringe conjecture wow
where yeah because you
you can't go back in time and prevent
your parents from meeting then you would
have never been born to have gone back
in time to prevent your parents from
meeting
wow so you've got to avoid those kinds
of
paradoxes that's it and it may be that
there's a law of physics that
prevents it we don't know by the way
this brings me to superman
if i may uh oh i always love when we
talk superman so go ahead
okay uh this i've said this in some
other videos but here and now it's
relevant
okay i got a call from dc comics some
years ago okay
and they wanted to have superman visit
the hayden planetarium all right
okay by the way that's i mean you know
just another
afternoon and the life of neil degrasse
tyson
you know hi neil well hello uh this is
dc comics just want to know if superman
i could drop by
okay all right
oh that's great you could have visited
two i didn't know
that oh that is so good that is so good
but go ahead so they wanted to know
superman could visit the hayden plants
and i said they wanted my permission i
said
sure and then they said well do you mind
if he meets you
in this and i said
sure okay okay of course we can meet
and then i asked what the story line was
the story line was
um he wants to use the observing
capabilities of the planetarium
to look back at krypton to see it get
destroyed
gotcha okay because he did a calculation
to realize that the light
from that episode which is when he was
born
was finally reaching earth right and so
he wanted to
witness this so i said all right wait
all right i said wait uh
you can't just do that unless one of two
things happens
either he traveled here in a wormhole
okay beating the beam of light right
okay because you can't go faster than
the speed of light but you might be able
to get places faster than the speed of
light
well what so he has to say right he has
to tunnel through space in some kind of
way
right and and we do know that
he arrived in you know moses style in a
basket
right not much older than when he was
launched
he shall deliver my people okay so
so go ahead and infants you you can tell
when they've aged weeks and even months
right
so here's an infant it's really no older
when it arrived than when it was
launched
so it got here basically instant or
excuse me or
it traveled at the speed of light and
didn't age
right traveled at the speed of light
then
the speed of light of the dying
civilization would have arrived at the
same time he did
right so thereby rendering it impossible
for him to forgive back at his past
so i told him it's got to be a wormhole
gotcha and this oh great when they're
taking notes and they're writing it down
fine so so we do this and then i said
well
how old is superman because this will
depend on
how you know how far away the star is
from earth
okay because if if he was launched when
he was born
at whatever age he is now that's how
many light years away the thing is
right okay that's how that works right
so they said he's
eternally in his late 20s
so i said okay by the way neil so am i
[Laughter]
so i asked him i said do you have um do
you want me to find you a star
a red star like krypton do you want me
to find you a red star at about that
distance and we could just declare that
to be superman's home home planet and so
you could do that i said yeah there's a
bajillion stars out there
went to the catalog found a star found a
red star found a red star 27 light years
away
boom there it is so now in superman
canon there is this star an actual star
in the night sky
which is where he came from and so and
he comes and then he observes it and
he's very sad because
he knew it happened intellectually but
then he sees it
as we recreate the image at the hayden
planetarium so that's actually
done in action comics 14. all right that
that's a really cool story
okay comics 14. that's in the comments
14. i got to give it to you man that
is a really and by the way i was
a little a little chubby then i'm a
little chubby now but i
so i said to the illustrator i said if
it makes no difference to you
could you take off a few pounds
i just asked and they said dr tyson this
is the world of the comics
everyone looks good yeah we're going to
give you a six-pack
kid yeah so i'm there standing poison
as i did in my youth right um and so
yeah it's a fun act if you want to find
action comics 14.
all right that's super cool man all
right it's in there i guess we should
move on even though
i guess so all right next question
that's precisely related to that
question yeah
i love it all right uh portuguese for
americans says
this for americans he says
he says what would happen if something
made earth rotate in the opposite
direction speaking of superman by the
way i did not plan this
i swear to god i did not plan this i
just happened to look down and this was
the next question that jumped out i
didn't even know it was coming up
and he says as christopher reeves did in
the superman movie
i can't believe that just happened but
that this is this is kismet
it must be meant to be uh so go ahead
wait what's the question oh yeah what
would happen if you actually did rotate
the earth backwards
what would happen okay so you stop us
first of all you stop us
and then you start us in the other way
what happens okay
so um you don't want this to happen
we all die that's the answer next
question
i was joking i really don't know what
happens uh what happens
it reminds me i recently tweeted about i
do tweet this every five years or so
um you know if you took all the veins
arteries and capillaries out of your
body and tied them end to end
okay you would die okay that's funny
all right that's a funny joke by the way
man that's
so i put that out there i like that and
then people get all serious with it
you realize you would die before you had
the chance to tie them into anger
people tried to analyze it now welcome
to my world
your premise is untenable sir okay
so anyway let's just say you you slow us
down to a stop because
it's worse than that okay it's worse
than you've ever been going fast in your
car
yeah and and someone puts on the brakes
in a steady slow down but it's it's you
put on very steady
in a steady slowdown you feel yourself
leaning forward the entire time the
brakes are applied thank god i have the
active restraint seat belt which
actually grabs me and pulls me back
because you're still going for you're
you're still feeling still feeling that
forward motion okay
while the earth is slowing down
everyone will lean
east what okay
all right this is cool all right
everybody will be
leaning at exactly the same at least
depending on how quickly
we slow ourselves down right okay so so
what
what you'll think of as vertical will be
a lean at that point
okay and you'll stay there until we stop
and as we come to a stop then you'll
stand erect again
okay but then we're not rotating so one
side of the earth will always
face the sun well this didn't last that
long right because he's sped right here
he's speaking
it's right there okay so that's fine
because otherwise you get a
very unequal heating of the earth and
that could wreak havoc
climactically but then he quickly sped
us up and had us go the other way so
then you lean
because now you were decelerating now
you're accelerating at any time there's
an acceleration
you're going to feel that as a sort of a
constant
right sort of lean okay and
so let me get it straight so if we
you'll you'll actually continue to lean
east is that right was accelerating this
way
yeah so you'll continue to lean east
because
the same force that slows you down and
speeds you up in the other direction is
the same force operating the whole time
wow okay okay so in other words he's
pushing against the rotation of the
earth
right and you lean against that but he
just keeps going through zero
and and rotates us back the other way
so that same force does that you'll feel
that lean and but he has to stop that
and then send it back the other way
so then you'll all be leaning the other
direction
until we're back to our normal speed but
nothing would have happened to
the timeline there is no backwards time
that is nothing
now what about the things that are not
the the
physical characteristics of the earth
that are not nailed down like well
since like that oh so sorry so all the
oceans
would slosh up yeah so the atlantic
ocean would begin to slosh up
onto europe and uh in africa
and the pacific would slosh up onto
thank you i forgot all about that
because the ocean is not
is not um stepping on the with friction
to the earth it has a slosh
with it yeah so you'll basically flood
all the continents so okay
so all right so there you go all right
well it depends on how important
basically superman killed everybody
killed everybody
when he did what just to save lois lane
by the way
by the way in the words of donald trump
not that hot
[Laughter]
well i'm told by people in the know
that there's a reason for that okay what
is it
because they if if loris lane were a
beauty queen
right then you as an average person
would not have access to superman
because if you're
you know you're not as beautiful as the
singular beauty queen right so they
drop her down a few notches closer to
sort of your average person
and then if you're an average person
then you can say oh i could
i can bag superman
i'm hot enough for superman i'm hot
enough you know you say what floss lane
can do really i can do this
no i can get them that would be totally
the the mindset right
exactly oh that's too funny uh so
now the problem is if he had stopped it
abruptly
then we'd all fall over and roll do east
800 miles an hour
and then that'd be the end of anything
that's not attached to the earth
yeah so but the fact that he did it
slowly means there's a chance you could
survive
right if you have a boat yeah if you
have a boat
chuck we got to end it there oh crap no
no i'm sorry
they're a little fun these are so much
gumbo and since they don't fit a
category they're their own
that's why they have their own flavor i
think that's why they're so much fun
because it's
just you just never know who's going to
ask what we got to do more all right
chuck always good to have you
always a pleasure tweeting at chuck nice
comment thank you sir
i don't follow many people i follow you
well thank you i follow you too
to the end to the ends of the earth to
the end even when superman is slashing
it full of water you got it
uh star talk cosmo aquarius neil
degrasse tyson as always
keep looking up
[Music]
you